What happens when 800 of the world’s most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof
Players stop being polite
and start getting real
This is
The Champions
Nice suit
Are you Marcelo’s new tax attorney?
I am speaking at charity event tonight
And you’re wearing this?
Uh..da?
OK hold on
I need to make a call
So today we’re going to be helping
one of the greatest playmakers in the game
Luka Modric
I love Luka
Luka is one of the most entertaining
creative footballers on the pitch
but off the pitch
he could use a little bit of help
And that’s where we come in
Hey, there he is!
Luka, what’s good, my man?
Hello
I understand you have to give a big talk
at the charity dinner tonight
Charity events are a great opportunity to
build your brand and to get great press
Luka’s gotta take advantage of that
and we’re here to show him how
Ugh. What is this shirt?
Checkers?
Ugh, gross
OK, you just offended all of Croatia
Ooh!
Haha
Wassap!
Er, please take that off
Luka’s style of dress should reflect his style of play
Sharp, creative, unpredictable!
Er, I don’t know about this
I know what your problem is
You need a neck tattoo
Come here!
OK
show me your celebration
Uh
Yea!
Just after a goal is the best time to take the focus
away from your team and on to you
But without a signature celebration
it’s like, why even score?
Now that Luka’s got his on-the-field celebration down
I need to show him how to celebrate OFF the field
Yo man
who are are these bobos?
That’s my wife and my kids
Luka’s a family man
and I respect that
I just want to expand his family to include
a few influencer models and maybe an American rapper
Luka, I want you to meet Tyga
Sup fam
Uh...hello
I don’t know who this weird ass Owen Wilson-looking dude is
but they’re paying me 10 grand a day so f--k it
So Luka’s got great hair
but he can do so much more with it
Now THAT’s a Galactico
Wow, you may not be a striker
but you look STRIKING
Oh, you’re going to kill it tonight
So remember
if I can go from refugee to Galactico
so can you!
So you guys have any questions?
Yes, you?
What is Sergio Ramos like?
Uh
What was it like playing with Ronaldo?
Um
Do you know Messi?
What?
Do you know Lionel Messi?
Uh
Oh no, he’s dying up there
What is this?
They still don’t care about him
Uh oh
I think we need to bring in the big guns
It’s-a me
Mario!
B-B-B-Balotelli!
Everyone gets a firework!